Így szinte hallom magamban, ahogy egyes
munkaadók pont ezt gondolják, hogyha
valaki cinikus alulteljesít, akkor nem
kiégett, hanem lusta. Nektek mi a
tapasztalatotok ezzel kapcsolatban?
>> Ez az egyik alapvető téphit, amit tök
jó, hogy behozol, mert ez ez erről
beszélni kell. Egyrészt nem csak a
cinikusság vagy a távolságtartás lehet a
jele a kiégettségnek. Ugyanúgy kiégést
tapasztalhat az is, aki nagyon sok
energiát tesz a munkában, és nagyon
ambiciózus, és többet túlórázik, és
[zene] egyáltalán nem egy ellenséges
attitűddel vesz részt a
munkafolyamatban, ugyanúgy jelen lehet
ez a formája is a kiégésnek.
الله